Let's go with that, I mean I don't
see anything better than this.
But if you think you can out
Solomon Solomon, more power to you.
>> Well, I believe that there
is a way out Solomon Solomon and
it really boils down to noting
what Solomon was trying to do.
What was Solomon trying to do?
>> Solomon was trying, they had private
knowledge of whether they were moms or
not, she was just trying to
get them to tell the truth.
>> Right, and
what he was trying to elicit
in this particular mechanism was
what their preferences were.
So, this sort of private notion of
whether they were the mom or not,
what was happening with what
King Solomon was doing was this kind of
assumption that each mom held the baby
and sort of with some kind of value.
So mom A in this case,
woman A in this case, loves the baby and
assigns some kind of value or
utility to having the baby around.
And woman B also has a value or
utility for
having the baby around versus having
the baby end up with the other woman.
>> Right.
>> And in particular, there's a value
of the baby to the true mother that is
higher than the value of
the baby to the fake mother.
>> Maybe, okay.
>> And in this case,
that better be what
King Solomon thought.
Because otherwise why would the fake
mother be okay with cutting
the baby in half?
>> Again, not necessarily okay,
just not as horrified.
>> Right, well,
that means there's a lower value there.
>> Right.
>> So there's
two values that are that
are actually going on and
let's say there's a value of
the baby for the real mother.
And there's a value of the baby for
the fake mother.
And really the only thing that we have
to sort of assume here is that the value
of the baby to the real mother is
greater than the value of the baby to
the fake mother.
>> Okay, which is also not so
clearly a good assumption?
>> Sure, but it certainly drives what's
going on with King Solomon here.
>> If value is like willingness to pay,
it could be that B is really rich but
isn't the mom and A is poor and
can't really pay very much.
But okay, all right,
let's just go with it, so.
>> I mean if-
>> We
want to know who wants the baby more.
>> Right, who wants the baby more,
sort of the intrinsic value of
the baby to each of the women.
And if you assume that the true
mother cares more about the baby,
that is has the baby at a higher value.
Then the fake mother then believing
this to be true makes sense.
>> Okay, I'll take it, sure.
>> And if that's not the case,
then you're kind of lost anyway.
So we might as well go ahead and
just sort of assume that this is true.
Anyway, if the fake mom had that
much money, she'll just buy a baby.
>> But
that's what she's trying to do [LAUGH].
>> No, she stole the baby.
>> Good point.
>> Okay, good.
So let's assume that we really believe
that there is a value to the baby to
the real mom and it's greater than the
value of the baby to the fake mom, okay?
So I'm just going to
assert another kind of mechanism
that King Solomon may have used.
>> Okay.
>> And I want you to walk me through it
and see if you believe
that this is good,
bad or the same as what King Solomon
actually did in the story.
Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> All right, so let me write that out.